it's my job to take care of you when you
need me
[Music]
and you need me it's so so many things
so many more things than i can possibly
say
um but it's it's really such an honor to
be
part of this moment um and
i'm i'm i'm so proud to be representing
my community in this way
at the same time i'm only one person and
i can't represent an entire community
um by myself and and so i'm so glad that
there are already so many amazing
disabled artists out there
doing such incredible work um ali
stroker for instance
ryan hatted lauren ridloff ryan
mcconnell
uh just doing doing such amazing work
and
and that um this will be the start of
much more
much more representation um so i'm very
proud to be part of this moment
but i i hope that it's just the
beginning i mean
nothing could feel better than doing
something that's on the right side of
history
you know i mean this is this is what you
know um
i think kyra mentioned if not now but uh
earlier you know she's the
she's this is the first movie with a
lead
performer using a wheelchair in 70 years
that those numbers are not are not right
do you know and i feel like um anytime
anytime you're a part of something that
is that is um trying to change the game
to a place as kira also said uh of
normalization
where it doesn't have to become this
this um
this rare thing but it becomes much more
commonplace
for people to see themselves on camera
represented
in a in a story or um on film
uh representing their life experience i
mean that's a very powerful thing um and
the most important thing is that you
know
anish and and the filmmakers were so
insistent
that this be what it needed to be and
and i think there was a little bit of
pushback only because they wanted
you know the assurance of having some
young
starlet who was you know going to get
butts in the seats when it came time to
release the movie
um but i always feel like the reason
people go see movies or
watch television programs is when
they're good and so what you want is the
person that is the most right
for the role and and and so i feel like
that that's what really happened here
you may not understand this right now
but i am doing what i know is best for
you
[Applause]
i actually my first in-person audition
in la
i had two self-tape auditions and then
two in-person auditions and my first
in-person audition when i first met
anish that weekend was the weekend
searching was coming out in theaters
um and so i went to to meet with him and
to audition for him
and then literally drove straight from
from my
audition to the movie theater and as i
was coming into the movie theater i
heard this voice
from across the lobby say hey i know you
and i turned around and it was a niche
he was
in in the lobby of the theater the day i
had my first audition he was there to do
a q
a for searching so there was a moment of
like very very much
meant to be a great moment of
synchronicity and and i i had to say to
him i'm sorry i can't talk to you
because i gotta go see your movie
um and and it was beautiful and
brilliant and
moving um and and i never knew what was
coming i
you know i cried i think my mom did a
fist pump at some point because she was
so invested in this story
um and it was a very surreal thing to be
leaving the theater after having spent
the afternoon with a niche
spent the evening watching this
incredible film and and
all i could think was i i have to do run
i have to do this film
it ultimately came down to me feeling
that it was a disservice
for me as a performer to have more
information
about what was wrong with the character
i was playing than the character
herself um i feel
often times people who are um afflicted
with these sorts of psychological um
troubles are not always aware that
that's what they're doing
and i didn't want to have more i didn't
want to be well researched
in a psychological affliction that that
diane didn't even know she had
so it was available to me i could have
done it
but as i started to do it i thought this
is making me feel too informed
about something that i think is just um
got diane by the throat
and and she doesn't have a diagnosis
from a doctor and she's not
in the care of the psychological care of
anyone so i don't think she would
know exactly even the consequence of
what she was doing
that the records show that mr fung is
pointing to the defendant mr orenthal
james simpson i mean i think one's
acting process is one's process
um regardless of the character you're
playing i've said before that i don't
know how to simulate
uh emotion and i don't know how to
simulate terror
um i only know how to call it forward to
experience it so
it's taxing and it's hard to sort of
live inside and it's hard to shake off
sometimes so
i think i probably will be stepping away
from some of that
kind of work in the near future just to
give my
my soul a tiny bit of a break
um that is uh i'm only three days into
shooting
so it's hard to say exactly what the
experience will be like but it is it is
certainly the biggest swing i've ever
taken uh
in my work life because um you know i
don't look like her
um and there's a lot had to go in to
sort of helping to
transform me which has been very
exciting and totally unnerving because
when you look in the mirror and you
literally can't see yourself or your own
sibling calls you on facetime and it's
like
what's happening right now um i sort of
live for the experience of someone
facetiming me when i'm in the fall
oh my god oh like it's a pretty
pretty great thing i wish i could snap a
picture every time it happens but you
know
it's different than playing marcia clark
marcia clark was um
a person i connected to immediately in
terms of a
a soul connection i had a lot of empathy
for her and i have empathy for linda too
uh i have empathy for for uh linda being
essentially an unseen person uh in her
work environment and
you know maybe in her life um certainly
not with her children who she loved them
very much and who loved her back um and
her
her husband um so i don't know it's too
new for me at the moment but
i do feel always an enormous
responsibility when playing a real
person
um i'm sensitive to the reality that
there are people who love her who are
still
walking around and at the same time
there's a part of the story that has to
be told and i have a responsibility not
to shy away from some of the
less flattering components of her
personality and or her choices
so you know we'll see talk to me in a
couple months we'll have
a we'll have a different conversation
[Music]
maybe